um this next story
makes yesterday's clip from the
interview that Donald Trump did with
Maggie Haberman even more extreme and
we're going to get to that in a moment
Donald Trump is now reported to have
personally packed a stash of documents
returned from Mar-A-Lago and he kept
hundreds more until the FBI sees them
remember all these questions about oh
did Trump know did Trump do it himself
of course not of course not the new
report per the Washington Post is that
Donald Trump personally packed 15 boxes
of material returned to Nara in January
he trialed but tried but failed to get a
lawyer to claim that was all he had
that's the previous story about Alex
Cannon many secret and classified
records were later found in an August
FBI raid at Mar-A-Lago remember that
yesterday we played a clip for you which
I'm going to play again right now as a
reminder of Donald Trump it's a
recording of Donald Trump talking to the
New York of the New York Times Maggie
Haberman where the question of documents
came up lo and behold it turns out Trump
was lying nation that you had with
Donald Trump where you brought up
the correspondence he had with North
Korean leader Kim Jong and the New York
Times released audio of this now we have
audio of this conversation so let's
listen
did you leave
with anything in particular are there
any Memento documents you took with you
anything nothing of great urgency okay I
have great things there you know uh
the letters the Kim Jong-un letters and
many of them you were able to take those
with you look at what's happening wow no
I think that has the I think that's in
the archives but most of it is in the
earth okay Trump knew when he made that
claim that he had taken a bunch of stuff
and the report now is he did it in
himself he did it himself and this puts
an entire new light on this entire story
took him himself allegedly
told his lawyer to lie about it and this
is the pattern looking for someone else
to take the fall now Alex Cannon made
the right decision made the right
decision to not sign off and say
everything's been returned he suspected
seemingly that Donald Trump was full of
you-know-what Christina Bob then signed
off on the document swearing we did a
sweep we know it's all gone from
Mar-A-Lago we don't have any more
documents now she has had to hire a
lawyer and this Last Detail because
remember all along at the end of the day
whether the documents were planted or
whether they were there or whatever
Eric Trump and others insisted Trump
doesn't personally pack he's a
billionaire he's the president he's not
personally stuffing documents into a box
the new report from The Washington Post
is that that is exactly what Donald
Trump did
and it certainly removes any Specter of
plausible deniability let's now see what
the latest claim is from Trump himself
I often have a very hectic schedule and
I don't always have the time to plan the
exact nutrition of all of my meals but
our sponsor athletic greens just makes
it easy to make sure I'm getting the
nutrients I want I've been using it for
almost a year now and it's great ag1 by
athletic greens is a delicious
plant-based blend of 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and probiotics from
whole food sources if I have just one
small scoop of ag1 a day I know I'm
getting the nutrition and nutrients that
I want that support all of the things
that are important to me the only
alternative would be to take 20
different vitamin pills and things every
day I'm not doing that I don't want to
do that ag1 is super tasty you can put
it in a smoothie I drink it straight
achieving good nutrition and feeling
your best does not have to be
complicated you can make AG one part of
your daily routine the way I have done
when you go to athleticgreens.com Pacman
you will get a one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs the
link is down below